we are celebrating our 99th episode
by counting down the top five films that
are 99 certified fresh on the tomato
meter
and number five it's the nine-time
oscar-nominated crime drama la
confidential which is on vod
set in 1950s los angeles three cops with
their own
brands of justice that's a subtle way to
say it
investigate a series of murders of
course because of the list it is
certified fresh at 99
on the tomato meter and has an audience
score of 94
swooping into the number four spot is
2017's
ladybird it's available on netflix and
vod greta going became a sought after
writer and director with his
coming-of-age tale starring cersei ronan
and laurie metcalf
it explores a mother-daughter
relationship and a young adult looking
to grow beyond the constraints of
suburbia
taking our number three spot on today's
special 99th
episode countdown is selma it's
available on vod
david yellow stars as dr martin luther
king jr in this drama
set during the fight for equal voting
rights in 1965.
ava duvenay directed the film which was
nominated for best picture at the 2015
oscars
selma was reviewed by 307 critics and
landed at the 99 percent mark on the
tomato meter
at number two director alfred
hitchcock's classic thriller
north by northwest is on hbo max and vod
cary grant plays a new york city ad exec
forced to go on the run
when a group of foreign spies mistake
him for a government agent
i'm an advertising man i've got a job a
secretary two ex-wives and several
bartenders depended upon me
crammed with iconic set pieces and
action scenes
north by northwest is considered one of
the greatest movies of
all time unless you're whitney balian at
the new yorker who just so
grieves in his 1959 review he complained
that it
lasts for a bloated two and a quarter
hours
and the endless chase sequences seem to
chase each other
maybe that's because it's a chase movie
that's the only rotten review for this
movie though
just saying alrighty then what's at
number one
scoring big at the 2020 oscars and
winning the top spot in our countdown
is parasite it's available on hulu and
vod
director bong joon ho created a
masterpiece that tackles issues of class
hierarchy in this thrilling korean
language film
the poor kim family come their way into
jobs with the wealthy park clan
paving the way for some terrifying
twists this movie's release
started so many conversations not only
about the changing genre the twists the
clever story
the captivating pacing but also the
challenges of classism
to me this movie was incredibly worthy
of all of those oscars
in my humble opinion let's recap shall
we la confidential
is only on vod ladybird is on netflix
and vod
you can watch selma on vod north by
northwest
is on hbo max and vod and parasite is on
hulu and vod
don't forget to follow us so you'll be
notified when a new rotten tomatoes
watch list goes live
until then go fourth and bin
you